encore une fois cette vidéo enregistrée plus tôt des activités de l'
équipage le jour du lancement, y compris
leur combinaison et leur arrivée sur la
rampe de lancement où ils ont été attachés au
module de descente maintenant pendant environ deux
heures et demie en cours de vérification des systèmes
et de communication avec les contrôleurs de vol
au bloc  maison à
baïkonour et au contrôle de mission en corée
à la périphérie de moscou
une fois que le soyuz atteindra son orbite préliminaire,
il sera contrôlé par les contrôleurs de vol
du centre de contrôle de mission russe
le spectateur obtiendra maintenant d'une caméra de balcon à l'
intérieur du contrôle de mission moscou
[Musique]
et ici, à Houston, les
équipes de contrôle de mission surveillent les systèmes à bord de la
station spatiale internationale en s'assurant que tous les
systèmes sont prêts pour l'arrivée de l'équipage
plus tard dans la journée, le directeur de vol qui dirige
les équipes de contrôle de mission à Houston
aujourd'hui est Jeff Radigan
[Musique]
maintenant seulement 12 minutes avant le décollage  et
tout est prêt,
le soja a été entièrement alimenté et tous les
systèmes  ms sont à nouveau en bonne
forme décollage prévu aujourd'hui à 1 h 38
heure centrale 12 h 38 et 15 secondes heure de
baïkonour
[Musique]
du soja alors que nous approchons de la marque t-moins
11 minutes pour lancer aujourd'hui
[Musique]
le lancement d'aujourd'hui mettra  mazurkin misawa
et hirano lors d'un voyage de six heures sur quatre orbites
vers la station spatiale internationale
avec un amarrage prévu au
module poisk du côté face à l'espace du
segment russe de la
station spatiale internationale
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[  Applaudissements]
[Musique]
préparation au lancement,
vous pouvez fermer la copie de votre casque au travail
cinq minutes de préparation au lancement en fermant
les casques
[Musique]
donc
nous avons nos casques fermés et les
aides de sauvetage sont amorcées
maintenant un peu moins de neuf minutes après le lancement
aujourd'hui les casques de l'équipage sont  fermé et
ils continueront à franchir ces
jalons pour le décollage à 1 h 38 et 15
secondes heure centrale 12 h 38 et 15
secondes heure de baïkonour
merci pour votre soutien et votre gentillesse
je vous les laisse
[Musique]
quoi
maintenant moins de huit minutes pour décoller
aujourd'hui et de retour sur le site de lancement, il fait
26 degrés Fahrenheit avec un ciel partiellement nuageux
[Musique]
j'ai rencontré
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
euh
s'il vous plaît signaler euh l'état à bord nous
copions le vélo  pas de lancement tout va
bien à bord
[Musique]
arrive dans six minutes pour décoller
aujourd'hui l'équipage à bord du soyuz ms20
signale que tout va bien à bord
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
étranger
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
six minutes et en comptant jusqu'au décollage
[Musique]
arrivant sur cinq minutes pour décoller,
ils devraient signaler une purge d'azote
pour la première étape
et obtenir des vues en cabine maintenant de l'
intérieur du soyuz
sur le côté droit de votre  l'écran est le
participant au vol spatial yusaku myazawa
à sa gauche est le commandant de soyuz alexander
mazurkin un
peu moins de quatre minutes pour décoller à
venir ensuite cette première étape sera
pressurisée à environ 2 minutes et 45
secondes avant de lancer la
pressurisation de la fi  les réservoirs de carburant du premier étage
optimiseront la pression du carburant en
aidant le support structurel de la
fusée lorsqu'elle repose sur la rampe de lancement et
les réservoirs d'appoint seront également
pressurisés
tout en état de préparation t-moins trois
minutes et en comptant,
nous confirmons l'oxydation et la vidange du carburant et la
sécurité  les vannes du lanceur sont fermées
la purge des conduites de carburant est maintenant
terminée
voici ma porte
nous confirmons que la pressurisation du réservoir de propulseur d'appoint a
commencé la copie
et que le réservoir d'appoint est maintenant
pressurisé pour le vol
t moins deux minutes et compte pour décoller
une autre vue de l'intérieur du  soyuz ms-20
moi-même sur la droite misurkin au
centre
[Musique]
maintenant à moins d'une minute et 30 secondes du
lancement à ce stade, l'
alimentation en propulseur au sol est maintenant terminée
et le soyuz est sur le point de passer à l'alimentation interne
qui arrive maintenant sur le  une minute marquer
45 secondes pour décoller
nous confirmons que le véhicule est connecté à l'alimentation interne
copiez le véhicule à l'alimentation interne le
premier ombilical se rétracte maintenant
nous con  séquence automatique ferme initiée séquence d'
ordre de copie initiée le deuxième
ombilical se rétracte maintenant
les
turbopompes d'allumage du moteur arrivent à la vitesse de vol la
deuxième tour ombilicale sépare
les turbopompes du moteur à la vitesse de vol
et au décollage
décollage du soyuz ms-20 avec deux
participants japonais au vol spatial et un
le cosmonaute russe
commence maintenant son voyage vers la
station spatiale internationale
[Musique] les
paramètres sont nominaux tout va bien
à bord nous nous sentons bien
[Musique]
30 secondes après le
début les équipages rapportent de bonnes performances au premier étage
[Musique]
le véhicule est stable
à l'intérieur du soyuz  commandant alexander
misurkin au centre et à sa droite
yusaku mayasawa
[Musique]
60 secondes de vol
paix royale
[Musique]
tout va bien à bord nous nous sentons
bien
l'équipage à bord se sent bien
[Musique]
une minute 30 secondes après le vol approche
au premier étage séparation
[Musique]
tout va bien à bord on se sent
bien
copier
[Musique]
on confirme  lancement du système d'évacuation
largage
[Musique] la
séparation du premier étage est confirmée
les quatre propulseurs à sangle ont
terminé leur travail
140 secondes de vol les paramètres du véhicule
sont une copie nominale
tout va bien à bord aussi nous nous
sentons bien
deuxième propulseur de sage
nous confirmons le largage du carénage du cône de nez
et nous pouvons à partir de cinq descentes de contrôle
et confirmation du linceul de lancement
larguer
les fusées à une altitude maintenant d'environ 49
miles de haut voyageant à une vitesse d'environ
5 203 miles par heure
le véhicule est stable obtenant une vue maintenant
depuis le booster soyuz
tout va bien à bord  copier
tous les paramètres du véhicule
signalés comme fonctionnant comme prévu alors
que nous approchons des quatre minutes de
vol
la situation à bord est nominale
également nous nous sentons bien copier
quatre minutes de vol et
tout fonctionne comme prévu et l'équipage
à bord  le soyuz ms-20 se sent bien
250 secondes de vol
rouler
nos
quatre minutes et demie nominales dans le vol
aujourd'hui  en attente maintenant de l'
arrêt du deuxième étage et de l'
activation de la séparation du
deuxième étage le moteur du troisième étage est opérationnel
tout semble bon maintenant voyageant un
peu plus de 9500 miles par heure et 100
miles d'altitude
les
cinq minutes et demie de vol le
soyuz est maintenant propulsé par le  seul
moteur du troisième étage du soyuz
nous nous sentons bien
tout va bien à bord aussi nous nous
sentons
bien après six minutes de vol l'équipage se
sent bien à bord ce
moteur du troisième étage brûle toujours comme prévu comme le
soyuz ms-20 et son équipage  dirigez-vous vers son
orbite préliminaire lors de son voyage vers la
station spatiale internationale
380 secondes de vol la
poussée du troisième étage fonctionne nominalement
tous les paramètres structurels encore signalés
comme étant nominaux alors que nous approchons de la
marque des sept minutes de vol ce matin
pour 20 secondes de
pas de roulis de vol nominal
tout va bien à bord nous nous sentons
bien copier
maintenant approcher sept minutes et demie de
vol le soyuz maintenant tra  veling 14 000
miles par heure 124 miles d'altitude
la trajectoire s'aplatissant sur
environ une minute de vol propulsé
restant
tout est nominal
maintenant à la marque de huit minutes de vol
depuis que le soyuz a décollé du véhicule
parcourant maintenant près de 15
500 miles par heure et 125 miles en
l'altitude
et tout va bien à bord nous nous
sentons bien avec gabi
tous les paramètres structurels encore
signalés comme nominaux